>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> John Kelly: Welcome everyone.
And if you've -- if
you've been sitting here
for the last few hours I
guess welcome doesn't apply.
But thank you for -- welcome
to me 'cause I just got here.
My name is John Kelly.
I'm a columnist at the Washington
Post, and I want to thank everybody
for coming to this, the tenth
annual National Book Festival,
which the Washington Post
has been delighted to sponsor
since the very beginning.
We like when people read things,
so thank you for reading things.
I need to tell you, if you
haven't heard it already,
that this is being video taped.
And so if you are in the witness
protection program, or you're trying
to hide from someone, you
should be aware of that,
because you may show
up on -- on camera.
Also, when -- when it's time to
ask questions we have microphones
in the aisles, so you can move to
a microphone to ask your question
so everybody can hear you.
I'm gonna be introducing
our next speaker and author.
And I should say that Rosemary Wells
has probably done more for rabbits
than anyone since Beatrix Potter.
Her Max and Ruby books
have entertained children
since the first one came
out in 1979 I think it was.
She may also be the country's
leading chronicler of noisy mice,
curious west highland
terriers, and sushi loving cats.
But Rosemary Wells is phenomenally
diverse, with a body of work
that includes not just books
to be read to children,
but books to be read by them,
and they their older brothers
and sisters, from Red Moon at
Sharpsburg, a young adult novel
about the Civil War battle
at Antetum, to My Havana,
memories of a Cuban boyhood,
a story inspired and written
with Secundino Fernandez,
a Havana-born architect
who captivated Wells, as well as
her latest book, On the Blue Comet.
Original, sensitive, incisive,
versatile, wry, these are just some
of the words used to describe her.
Rosemary once wrote in
the Washington Post,
my childhood is irreplaceable,
and the greatest gift that I own.
Through the more than 120 books she
has written over the last 40 years,
I think that she's given
an immeasurable gift
to countless other childhoods.
So please welcome Rosemary Wells.
[ applause ]
>> Rosemary Wells: It's --
it's really hard for me
to believe any of that.
To me I'm just the --
the mother who used
to do the late away games
driving for Sacred Heart
for my kids in soccer and lacrosse.
I used to have to go all
over Westchester County
to unknown schools and pick up about
seven girls 'cause I was qualified
to -- to drive a van.
And that's who I really am.
I wanted to in this late afternoon
on this hot, hot beautiful day,
at this wonderful symposium
give a little thanks out,
first to the marvelous red-shirted
volunteers who proliferate --
[ background applause ]
all over this wonderful fair.
>> Rosemary Wells: Thank you.
Thank you for your hard work,
thank you for your courtesy,
thank you for your love of books
or I know you wouldn't be here.
There's another person who
is not here in this audience,
I'm quite sure, but I think that she
deserves a little bit of thanks too.
I believe that the greatest legacy
of the Bush administration
was Laura Bush's festival.
[ applause ]
>> Rosemary Wells: I had an
interview earlier today with --
with a couple of wonderful writers
from -- from a magazine that --
that is basically the magazine that
preschool teachers enjoy and --
and read and write letters to.
And they asked me if I had -- are
these microphones loud enough?
Can you all here me?
Okay. They asked me if I would
say anything about using books
with kids, and -- and the reason
to do it, and how to do it, and --
and that kind of a question.
And I wanted to answer it and --
and hope that there's lots
of teachers in this audience.
Are there teachers in this audience?
[ applause ]
>> Rosemary Wells: Bless you.
You are -- you are the most
important professionals
in American life today.
[ applause ]
>> Rosemary Wells: In your hands --
in your hands are our young
people, and our future.
And I do wish you were all
paid as well as lawyers.
[ applause ]
>> Rosemary Wells: We'll get
back to the teachers in a minute,
because I love teachers, and I
love to advocate for teachers.
And the one terrific thing that I --
I like about being a writer
is no one can really fire me,
so I can say whatever I want.
[ laughter ]
At any rate, I answered these two
lovely young teachers this morning
by saying, all I ever intend
to do with Max and Ruby,
or with The Blue Comet, or anything
else I write and illustrate is
to cause children to open a
book and look at those pages,
and love what's inside, and to
love the privacy that a book gives.
I always write for the
most intelligent child.
I never dumb anything
down like the TV does.
TV does nothing but
dumb things down.
They write for children so dumb that
those children don't even exist.
I write for the brightest child,
knowing that that bright child
can live right here in DC,
that bright child can come from the
South Bronx, or the furthest reaches
of rural America, I
don't know where,
but the poorest, poorest areas.
And I know that child is there,
and that's the child I write for.
I want them to open those pages, and
I want them to love what they find.
And not just my books, any books.
I want them to love books.
I don't want to write a book about
what you should do or should think
or should feel, I never do that.
I write -- really, Max
and Ruby is non-fiction.
[ laughter ]
If you think about it,
if you think about it,
because it's all real,
it's all my kids.
And -- and -- and universalized.
And -- and I just want children to
-- to have that great joy that I had
when I was little and I opened --
cracked the pages of a Nancy Drew.
There was no greater joy,
no greater joy in my life
than one night I remember when
my daughter was about nine --
my daughter Victoria was about nine
years old and I wanted her to go
to bed, and she had to get
up early, and I was yelling
at the bottom of the stairs.
I said sweetheart, it is long past
time for bed, and I see that crack
of light under your door.
Nothing happened.
I said five minutes and that's it.
Six minutes past and I had
to go up there finally.
And I knocked on the door.
I said it is time for bed, you have
a math test tomorrow and you know
when the bus comes, and you're
not gonna get your sleep,
and you have to eat your breakfast.
She looked up startled.
There she was with a
Nancy Drew in her --
in her lap, and not you
might notice a vampire novel
or a dystopian novel.
She was there with a Nancy Drew,
and she said oh Ma, I'm so sorry.
I didn't really hear you, because
nothing in the room existed.
Even I didn't exist, only
what's in this book, I was gone.
And the thing -- you
know, you never can --
you never can prevent
what you really think,
and it just goes skipping through
your head without any warning.
And I said okay, I can die now.
[ laughter ]
Back to those teachers.
Critical thinking is what they're
going to get when they love books.
They're not gonna open a
book if they don't love it.
They're not gonna open a book
if you whip the book to death
with questions and all kinds of
things that invades the privacy
of the reader and the story.
[ applause ]
With all these prepared teacher
questions, it's just terrible.
Children hate them.
They want that book
to be a private thing.
Unfortunately, a great many of them
don't have the privacy of reading
by themselves or the privacy
of reading with a parent,
and it's up to the teacher to do it.
There are three things that
happen to those children,
and they are totally important.
One is the art of critical thinking,
the art of not following
say a politician and voting
for that politician who
talks in bumper stickers.
[ applause ]
>> Rosemary Wells: And talks about
-- and talks -- and talks unfairly,
and -- and hatefully
to other politicians.
That child is gonna critically think
right around that and say, you know,
I want to hear the other
side of this question,
I want to hear the
other point of view.
That's what a reader is.
A reader is also someone
who escapes.
The richest children among
us still want to escape.
They still want to
escape from something,
no matter what it is,
they want to escape.
And that's what books give us.
And it also gives us a private
scaffold to adventure and knowledge.
And when I -- I use the word
scaffold very, very carefully,
because it's an educationee's word,
and I don't like educationee's
very much at all.
I speak the English
of my grandmother.
I speak the English language of
1943, and I haven't changed a thing.
But I will -- I will
use the world scaffold,
because it is the difference
between television and books.
Television is not scaffold --
scaffolded to the individual
child -- that child's interests,
that child's reading skills,
that child's abilities.
The child can pick
from hundreds of books,
and find the books
that's right for them.
And the books give them a scaffolded
bridge of safety with handrails
to escape, to gain knowledge,
and to simply have fun.
All I can do is make it
fun to open those covers.
And that's what I hope to do.
I had the privilege of speaking
a little bit earlier to one
of our most distinguished
guests who's sitting somewhere
in this audience.
I won't point her out, but she is
the daughter of a great President.
He was born in Texas.
He would never have made it
to Congress or the first thing
without a tremendous
drive for education,
without books and libraries.
And we're not going to have a
generation of children who are
of this kind at all, unless
we get them back into books.
I worry about our democracy.
[ silence ]
>> Rosemary Wells:
You will excuse me.
I'm a grandmother to four,
and they pick up things in --
in school that grab
hold of the sinuses
of the adults that
are just terrible.
So I'm gonna -- I think
I have a little water.
We are in danger of losing this
wonderful democracy of ours.
The one solution and the one thing
that's gonna save it is education
and books.
[ applause ]
>> Rosemary Wells: Because
you can't have a democracy
without an educated population,
and without critical thinkers.
It means hard work.
It means not allowing
video games in your home.
You can't prevent them, but you
can not allow them in your home.
Excuse me.
I'm really sorry, I'm
doing the best I can.
I think that the value of the book,
and the value of the
educated parent,
and the participatory
parent cannot be overstated.
It's very interesting.
There's a recent This Week Sunday
Morning program, again excuse me.
If anybody's got a cough
drop I would love one.
[ silence ]
>> Rosemary Wells: That's
wonderful, thank you.
Thank you.
[ silence ]
>> Rosemary Wells: A recent Sunday
Morning Christine Amanpour program
on education had the three
biggies, Arne Duncan,
Michelle Rhee Welker
[phonetic], and Randi Weingarten.
These are the three big
educational movers and shakers
in the United States at this time.
[ silence ]
>> Rosemary Wells: They talked about
funding, they talked about unions,
they talked about teachers, they
talked about Michelle's plan
to reward good teachers, and
basically get rid of the ones
who were not -- thank you
-- who were not up to snuff.
I don't disagree with that.
I think it's a good plan.
I do think that the teachers union
has overdone their protection
of teachers, whether good or bad.
And the research will show how
important a good teacher is,
particularly to a child who
is poor and from the ghetto.
[ applause ]
This couldn't be better stated,
apparently, I haven't said it yet,
but in the movie Waiting
for Superman,
which is coming to all the theaters.
But I noticed one thing
about the conversation.
The three biggest educational
movers and shakers
in this country never mentioned
the contribution of parents.
This is critical.
The best teacher in the world can't
overcome a parent who simply turns
on the television, or doesn't
read to their children.
This is something --
[ applause ]
>> Rosemary Wells: This is something
that we need to get out there.
And I have to say I've seen a
couple of big changes in my time
as an American that I never
believed would happen.
Again, excuse me.
[ silence ]
>> Rosemary Wells: When I was
little we used to have Sunday lunch
at my grandmother's
big house by the sea.
And the room was always
blue with smoke.
And there would be the rattle of
old fashioned glasses with ice.
And we'd sit down to lunch to
roast pork and creamed spinach,
and other things like that.
And those sweet people
would never have believed
that you could get Americans going
and running around like rabbits,
that America would -- at least
a lot of us, completely give
up the drinking and smoking,
or drinking to excess.
None of them would have believed it.
We can do this.
We can do this in this country.
But it's a great unmentionable
to talk
about the parents and
their contribution.
And I think we need to be frank,
honest, and come out with this.
Again, excuse me.
[ silence ]
>> Rosemary Wells: Two
courses of antibiotics.
[ laughter ]
Didn't do any good.
30 days, and I'm just
getting over it.
So today I brought
you three new books.
I'm going to check the time.
I'm also going to answer questions.
So very quickly, this
is Max and Ruby.
It's Max and Ruby's Bedtime book.
And it's three stories,
instead of one.
I had some stories that I wanted
to make into picture books,
and they never really gelled
because they weren't long enough.
Again, excuse me.
[ silence ]
>> Rosemary Wells: They
weren't really long enough.
So I collected them, and
I thought about them,
and I made them into
shorter stories.
And so you'll find them all here.
They are Ruby's Restaurant, I know
you can't see it, and I had intended
to have a PowerPoint show.
But Ruby's Restaurant is all about
Ruby and Louise, her best friend,
and how they open a cafe,
with grandma as the one
eater or client, customer.
And they forget completely, with
their huge store of rubber food.
Now people ask me how
do my children --
how do my children contribute
to -- to the ideas for books.
Well, I have twin granddaughters,
and they own probably
about 30 different
pieces of rubber food.
[ laugher ]
It's wonderful.
[ silence ]
>> Rosemary Wells: They have rubber
hamburgers, they have rubber sushi,
they have rubber lettuce,
rubber milk, rubber butter.
It's just wonderful what they make.
And they make these huge
meals out of this rubber food.
So that's right in this book.
But Ruby and Louise forget
entirely about dessert.
So it is left to Max to go
upstairs, and to take the bottle
of baby shampoo, and to
go into the potting shed,
and to mix it with potting
soil, which he does,
and make the most wonderful
chocolate mousse,
which he serves to his grandmother.
And of course, she's thrilled.
There's another story in
here about Max rescuing a --
rescuing a dolly of his -- of his
sister's best friend little sister,
and then another one
about Max goes to school.
That is Max.
I have two other books that
I would like to bring to you,
because I know I'm
known for picture books,
but I also am a very
ardent novel writer.
This one again, no
vampires, and no dystopia.
A very positive and cheerful book
nonetheless, a time travel book
with a big crime in the middle of
it, and set in our depression era
in the 1920s in Cairo [phonetic],
Illinois, Hollywood, and New York.
I wish I had time to
read you a little of it,
but my voice is not good enough
to honor the book,
so I'll put it aside.
And then the last one, I think
there are some copies left.
This one is called My Havana.
About five years ago I was listening
to NPR, and heard the story just
in five minutes of a man
who had left Cuba I think
as a nine-year old
when Castro came in.
And the thing in his
story that stuck with me
for the next four years was how
much he missed his beautiful city
of Havana, and how much he pined
for it, and how cold and grey
and icy New York was,
where his family had to go.
So this was in 1958.
New York did not necessarily
welcome Hispanics, excuse me.
[ silence ]
>> Rosemary Wells: And he
was not a happy camper.
Nonetheless, he built out
of cardboard an entire city
of Havana on his bedroom floor.
It was a miracle.
And by spring he'd
made a best friend,
and learned about Coney Island,
and the fact that New York too
could be warm, and had a beach.
The story stayed with me.
I couldn't find Dino
Fernandez, I had his name wrong.
But I finally did find
him, and wrote his story.
At this point I will
ask for some questions,
and do my best to answer them.
Again, forgive me.
I have not been coughing
very much today,
but it's the speaking
that brings it on.
So let's see if anyone
has some questions,
and I'll do my best to answer them.
[ silence ]
>> Rosemary Well: Yes.
>> How did you get the idea
for writing Ruby and Max?
>> Rosemary Wells: Ruby and
Max are my own two children.
And can you believe it?
Ruby is 37-years old,
[ laughter ]
mother of three, and
still really bossy.
[ laughter ]
Max is 32-years old and
teaches horticulture at Cornell,
and is still really dirty.
[ laughter ]
Thank you.
[ applause ]
>> Rosemary Wells: Yes.
>> What inspired you for
the Bunny Cakes book?
>> Rosemary Wells:
The Bunny Cakes books.
I can't even tell you.
These books -- they just come to me.
Have you ever seen an airport
where the planes are in the air
and you see the lights
of the planes,
and the planes start to land.
There are three, four, or
five, six planes out there.
Well that's how the ideas are.
They come out of the clouds, and
they try to land at my airport.
Now I have a lot of
books going all the time.
And sometimes they have to
go in a holding pattern.
And then they say you better
let me land or I'll go
down to the Kevin Hankus
[phonetic] Airport.
[ laughter ]
>> Rosemary Wells: Thank you.
>> I just want to say first thank
you so much for coming and talking
to us today with such great spirit,
even though you're
not feeling too great.
>> Rosemary Wells: I feel just fine.
This is an attack.
And of course it would
come at the time
where I'm speaking to all of you.
I feel fine, this doesn't hurt,
it just is really annoying.
>> And secondly, I wanted to ask the
title of your new time travel book.
>> Rosemary Wells: A title for what?
>> The time travel book that's --
that you brought to show us today?
>> Rosemary Wells:
On the Blue Comet.
>> Thank you.
>> Rosemary Wells: It's about Oscar
Ogleglee [phonetic] who is not --
who's 11-years old,
lives in Cairo, Illinois,
and has the most wonderful train
set which he runs with his father.
>> Good afternoon.
I'd like to know how
long you've been writing,
what were you doing prior
to, and how did you feel
about the rejections you got when
you first submitted your work?
>> Rosemary Wells: I
was very fortunate.
Excuse me for a minute.
[ silence ]
>> Rosemary Wells: I was very
fortunate in that I worked
for the publisher who
first published me.
>> Wonderful.
>> Rosemary Wells: And I
didn't have any rejections.
>> Wonderful.
>> Rosemary Wells: If
I had them, knowing me,
I would have felt terrible.
But I didn't have any.
I learned how to do it
because I was in publishing.
>> Thank you so much.
>> Rosemary Wells: You're welcome.
[ silence ]
>> Rosemary Wells: I'm sorry to come
to you with such a terrible cold.
Thank you for being
so understanding.
Yes, another question.
Yes?
>> When did you start writing
the Max and Ruby books?
>> Rosemary Wells: When my daughters
were 9-months old and 5-years old,
and that was about 30 years ago.
Yes?
>> What is your favorite book?
>> Rosemary Wells: What
is my favorite book?
The ones that I've written?
Right now, On the Blue Comet
and Max and Ruby's Bedtime book.
[ laughter ]
>> Thank you.
>> I do not necessarily
have a question.
I just want to thank you for
bringing such joy to our family.
And I also want to thank
you for your words today,
recognizing the part a parent
takes in a child's life.
And I hope you get better
soon, God bless you.
>> Rosemary Wells: I
will get better soon.
I'm so terribly sorry,
but as you can imagine,
everybody's here had
a terrible cold,
and you all know what it's like.
Again, there are a lot
of people with questions,
I would like to take them all.
I would just like to re-emphasize
the main point of what I came here
to say, which is our parents
need to step up with our kids.
[ applause ]
>> Rosemary Wells: For our teachers.
>> Rosemary Wells:
You know, there's a --
a big scandal about a
Los Angeles Times article
that rated teachers
publicly from bad to good.
And there was a lot of talk
about whether this fair
and whether it was right.
And I don't know whether
it was fair or right,
but I don't think you
should rate those teachers
without rating the parents.
I think we should --
[ applause ]
>> Rosemary Wells: I
think we should talk
about how our parent --
whether our parents --
>> Rosemary Wells: -- are sending
our kids to school prepared.
It's about all I can
say, my time is up.
I thank you so much for coming.
[ applause ]
[ silence ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.